[Musique]
l'hôpital des enfants fête ses 70 ans un
bel anniversaire célébré en présence
d'autorités qui œuvre dans le domaine de
la santé mais aussi de personnel
soignant et quelques figures
emblématiques de la construction de cet
hôpital cette célébration est surtout
l'occasion de rendre un hommage à sœur
colollette qui a largement contribué à
l'avancée médicale pédiatrique et la
protection infantile à la Réunion c'est
une pédiatre venue de Paris qui s'est
engagée à 33 ans à l'hôpital d'enfants à
la Réunion et qui a fait fait ses vœux
pour devenir sœur en
1953 et donc de 53 à 1976 elle a été
pédiatre à l'hôpital d'enfant et elle a
permis le développement d'un l'hôpital
moderne la réunion a connu d'importante
évolution dans le domaine médical et en
ce 22 juin fêté les 70 ans de l'hôpital
est bien le moment pour faire un travail
de mémoire un hôpital ne peut pas
avancer dans l'avenir s certains moment
il ne se retourne pas vers son passé
tellement il y eu un chamboulement en
plus à la réunion entre les les années
40 50 et aujourd'hui en 50 ans il y a eu
un développement extraordinaire de la
Réunion et dans le domaine de la santé
ça se vérifie également pour les soins
pédiatriques il y a 60 ans quand solat
est arrivé il y avait quoi les personnes
âgées les publics vulnérables les mamans
qui couché n'avait rien ni personne et
les conditions étaient des conditions
très précaires et sa vie le parcours de
sa vie humaine rejoint le parcours
collectif de la mise en place de la
santé publique en faveur des publics
vulnérables le vieux mooun et l'enfance
ça reste encore aujourd'hui des
préoccupations des élus que nous sommes
les enfants de l'hôpital ont ensuite pu
assister à un spectacle pour continuer
la fête le département tient à apporter
son aide à la é afin d'offrir le
meilleur à ces usagers qui en ont
[Musique]
besoin